hello everyone and welcome back to yet
another episode of rotten tomatoes is
wrong and sir we are back for a family
affair a drama that is near and dear to
both of us or at least near and dear to
someone near both of us mr mark ellis
how you doing sir i am great jacqueline
and i'm i'm perplexed by your intro
because sometimes you do the hello
everyone like i do sometimes you do the
hey y'all and i thought we were getting
to hey y'all here because the movie
we're talking about sort of harkens back
to your hometown of corpus christi texas
yes
it's so weird so i moved to corpus when
i was seven
and so like it's mostly where i'm from
but my mother really tried to keep as
much alabama in our house as possible
but nothing
could come against the wave that is
selena quintanilla perez that was her
full name and she was a juggernaut in
corpus christi she was the biggest like
star
when i was growing up in middle school
in fact
she died in march we were just coming
back from spring break and the girls in
my school cried in the hallways
for a good month and i'm not
exaggerating whatsoever
i remember hearing about it and then
it's like the next day the movie was
just out and and everybody was was
raving about the movie and so unless
it's a made for like tv sort of lifetime
movie you really don't get a turnaround
like that with a horrific tragedy of a
beloved star and then the movie
especially one that that ends up being
as great as selena and that's you know
just our opinion on it rotten tomatoes
has it it's 67 percent is that yeah
right 67
fresh and a 77 fresh audience score our
guest today i feel is going to object
vehemently to those assertions
as anybody who's seen the film and has
any like modicum of attachment to selena
will do but we are going to welcome him
on in just a bit harvey again he plays
guillermo de la cruz in hulu's what we
do in the shadows and i think you know
friend rt he's really great and
absolutely hilarious i cannot wait to
talk to him about this movie he actually
we had to keep going to find the movie
that that reached his heart and when he
saw selena he said yes and shout out to
brian perez who was the one who
suggested this title to him to allow him
to be like yeah let's go to selena way
to go brian i know but uh before we do
that sir mr mark ellis can you give us
the who what where why uh happens in
selena from 1997. i certainly can selena
is what the kids call a biopic as i used
to pronounce them biopics until i was
forced to change and it is about selena
quintanilla who was born into a very
musical family that was mexican-american
and like jacqueline said about 15-20
miles from corpus christi texas and her
father abraham is played by the
wonderful edward james almost and you
see that she's talented and they sort of
perform together and then she finds a
lot of success she's rising through the
ranks she falls in love with someone
else in one of her bands and that's not
gonna please poppy all that much and so
you have this person at the crossroads
that every musician faces where they're
stardom and it's just a step away i've
already gotten a lot of popularity
people love me and then
we have tragedy in that final act where
selena is
sadly
shot
and killed and she had so much life left
to live so much music left to give us so
much beauty to put out there in the
world
and it is jennifer lopez who is playing
this lead character the titular
character in selena
very well done sir i i as we will
discuss later i have a feeling you've
seen this movie one or two times but
there's i i have some influences in my
life that have uh that have opened my
eyes to the greatness of selena because
again i remember it happening i did see
the movie initially maybe five six years
after it came out but then circumstances
as they are i met somebody still very
close to me who is a monster selena
enthusiast and thankfully she is because
i love that this is this is not a movie
we had to introduce you to this was one
where you felt right at home but before
we dive into it and talk to harvey let's
go ahead and venture back to what the
critics and audiences were saying back
in 1997 with one of my favorite segments
i just cannot wait to hear the music
play where tim ryan tells us what
happened in two minutes with him
[Music]
every death is a tragedy but the murder
of selena quitania perez felt especially
cruel here was a young woman who was
beloved by her legion of fans and those
who knew her and who was on the verge of
super stardom before she was killed by
somebody she trusted a movie biopic was
inevitable and selena had a huge asset
in its favor a breakout performance by
jennifer lopez in the title role that
captured the essence of his subject that
said while critics praised the film's
warmth and performances a few felt that
it suffered from an overabundance of
musical biopic cliches selena is fresh
at 67 on the tomato meter with 48
reviews and it has a 77 audience score
so what did the critics have to say in a
fresh review jean oppenheimer of box
office magazine wrote jennifer lopez is
sensational she not only looks
remarkably like the real star but she
radiates the same incredible energy
warmth style and magnetism for which the
young pop singer was known however in a
rotten review edward guthman of the san
francisco chronicle wrote that the film
was only so-so but lopez is so vibrant
that you almost forgive the movie's
paint by numbers script and moldy
formula the rotten tomatoes critic's
consensus reads
selena occasionally struggles to tell
its subject's story with depth or
perspective but those flaws are rendered
largely irrelevant by jennifer lopez in
the title role so that's celaena back to
you folks oh thank you very much tim for
that i i literally feel i was i was back
in corpus christi
striving with every fiber of my being to
leave
just listening to you talk about it um
but look you don't take my word for it
um about corpus or selena that we are
going to have i think a kind of selena
expert come and chat with us so why
don't we go ahead and welcome to the
podcast harvey gian and have a listen to
our chat with him about selena
[Music]
hello everyone so we are here to welcome
harvey ginn he plays the scene stealing
guillermo de la cruz from hulu's what we
do in the shadows emmy nominated who's
what we do in the shadows harvey's here
to chat 1997 film selena starring
jennifer lopez and his role in what we
do in the shadows which is now in season
three harvey thank you so much for being
here thanks for having me good to see
you again yeah it's gonna be really fun
to chat i feel like i've kept up with
you a little bit because i follow you on
instagram now and you are a favorite
follow i was so happy that you picked
this um harvey really quick let's go
ahead and break down the the ins and
outs of this uh came out in 1997 it's 67
which is still a travesty because it
should be certified fresh at like 95 but
it does have a 77
fresh audience score and so just to have
your definitive answer
is rt wrong about selena and what do you
think the score should be yes yes it
sounds
um no it should definitely be like i
would say closer to 98 or like up there
like it's like for me it's like
you know of course i'm biased because i
actually grew up listening to selena
music and it was like a huge deal in our
household um and so
for me it was like a hundred i wanted to
be a hundred but you know like any
project nothing's perfect and that
thing's you know a hundred percent but
it should be it should be pretty close
to 100 i think personally it's actually
a great film and it did a great justice
to telling the story of selling nicki
dania so i think it should be you know
up there yeah also let's talk about it
and this movie was made so close after
her death um i'm curious when because i
feel like you must have been two you
must have been two when this came out
but when did you first see uh the film i
first saw the film actually on dvd and i
think we rented it uh or got it like one
of those like box uh things and it was
kind of a
an eye opening moment for me because i
growing up we didn't see a lot of you
know latinx representation on film
especially in a lead so for me it was
kind of like jennifer lopez portraying
selena was kind of a huge huge moment
for me just to be like she's doing it
she's doing it it's possible you could
actually you know do this uh because up
until then i don't think we've had a lot
of films that necessarily revolve around
latinx actors um and that's unfortunate
because uh we are like you know what is
it something ridiculous like 65 percent
of uh theater goers or something like
that you know
yeah so it's a huge thing and so i was
um i was really encouraged to continue
to want to be an actor when i watched it
so i think it has a special place in my
heart because it kind of uh gave me this
extra boost of confidence when i watched
it oh great mark what about you sir uh
what do you feel about it
was this the first time you obviously
not danny has made you watch selena at
some point in your
knowing this woman i feel like if she
did it made me watch it it's a strong
word like
it was like okay twist my arm cause i am
obviously
a huge jennifer lopez fan i think she's
great i love edward james almost and so
those were really the
the ends that i had to watching and
witnessing the power of selena so i'm
happy that it is fresh i'm happy it's 67
but i agree with harvey i think it
should be much higher but what i love
about this movie and i think the biggest
reason why i think rotten tomatoes is
wrong and is short-changing selena is
the powerhouse performance from jennifer
lopez the star-making turn that we all
got to witness but also that quiet
emotional storm until it's time to not
be quiet of whatever james almost says
abraham selena's father thinking about
how quickly they got it
in production and how quickly they were
able to tell her story after her death i
mean this was still a time harvey can
recall when like her music was just
dominating the airwaves both her english
language stuff and her old stuff because
people just really did not want to let
her go and this film felt like an
extension of that um in in so many ways
so
i i don't know it's uh it's it's a movie
that i can't really separate from my
time uh living there and then also
just the intense reaction uh everyone
had to
uh selena quintanilla's uh untimely
death but we'll get into all of that but
let's go ahead and just first
talk about the film um i saw it back in
97 at tinseltown but harvey for you
when you were watching it on dvd were
you already a huge fan of selena's music
at this point like when did you know
like the the division i i was a big fan
my mom was a big fan um and i just uh i
just remembered that the music was
played constantly like we would clean on
weekends so like on weekends like she'd
bump up the music and it was like
gargantua would be playing and she'd be
like cleaning like you know the living
room unlike or you know or baby
like all the songs so i grew up almost
like a like nursery rhymes
yeah so i would fall asleep to like you
know in the background in the corner i
could still hear a little bit of the
music on the weekend and stuff uh
because it was the weekends where like
you know
cleaning and you know and you have to
have a good time when you're cleaning so
she put on the music and and it just
made it so nostalgic for me in a way
because i watching the movie was so a
part of my culture and watching it on
the big screen again validated my you
know like my being and like the culture
that i i'm so proud and love to be a
part of that it was just like nice to be
like it's up there it's up once like
there yeah and then when they have the
restaurant and the movie when they go
you know they own the xmix restaurant
like all those little things i was like
we go to mexicans all the time like that
was just nice to see it represented on
screen and uh and and almost like a
reflection of yourself so it was just
really nice uh to put those together
growing up with the music and then
watching the movie falling in love with
jennifer lopez honestly before that i
don't think i had ever seen or heard of
jennifer lopez until i saw her place and
then i became obsessed i was like oh who
is she like yeah and then of course he
went on to do everything under the sun
yeah exactly no this was definitely the
moment i mean i remember watching this
and being like is that the fly girl like
i literally was like
this is the fly girl from from the
living color and and that's who she was
for a long time for me um
even when she was making hits that were
on the radio uh kind of breaking it down
to the movie which first of all i have
to say i also you could not live in
corpus without being exposed to
so much tejano music especially selena
and there was a sunday morning program
that was a spanish language program that
i did not understand a single word of it
but i still watched it and it was
domingo
did you did you ever have domingo yeah
yes so we had domingo and corpus and i
didn't understand anything that was on
the thing but i knew they were going to
play music and i also knew the guy from
primer impacto
the astrology guy yeah
was gonna pop up and so literally every
sunday i would watch domingo and and
like you know listen to the music
because the music is translatable no
matter what um
such a great that was a netflix
documentary about walter it was so good
and eye-opening for me who had never
heard of him but again going back to
danny because that's all we talk about
on the show is is my exes apparently but
danny
like knew him from her childhood and so
she got to see that and so that was that
was just another like kind of in into
into this culture because i like you
never really put together that you've
heard tejano music your whole life just
living anywhere in america really and
then when we watched it for the first
time
as soon as the music kicks in i'm hooked
because i'm such a sucker for great
music and especially like peppy happy
upbeat music
there's nothing better than that
absolutely um more accurately though too
uh jennifer lopez is also very
recognizable in the what's love got to
do with the video with jenny jackson
because she was one of her backup
dancers like girl has made an evolution
let's get down to the actual meat of the
film though there's so many great scenes
from this movie like it is one of those
ones that you want to queue up and have
like the moment and so there's a few
that like stand out but i'm just curious
harvey since there are little touches
that mean more to you if maybe there's
like a deep cut scene for you or but
there's like plenty of the greatest hit
scenes as well
i mean i really love the it's such a
horrible thing to say i love the way
that lupe altiveros played yolanda just
because it was i just just hated her
and that's a good actress when you're
such a you know she's doing such a
phenomenal job that from the gecko
you're like just
i just don't like you you know and
although i love luco
and funny story she was supposed to play
my mom
in a film um and she was cast and
everything and nadine velazquez and i
played sister and brother and uh the
week before we started production uh
lupe passed away
unfortunately and she was supposed to
play my mom in the film and i was like
oh my god it's it's yolanda from selena
so i was literally living my life i was
like she's gonna tell me mom oh my gosh
and then unfortunately that was the week
that she passed away that's so sad to
hear but such a great like inside story
which yes there's a meme that goes
around um
like uh like the internet especially in
like latinx circles where it was like
when you see this actress on screen you
know you're about to get mad or sad
immediately because she like she very
much played so many of those characters
because she was also in real women have
curves
yeah and like that for folks that don't
know that was ladybird but with less
wives she was the the mother-in-law
desperate housewives so she always she's
such a great character actress that
every time you're just like oh she's so
good at these roles yeah i just loved it
and i was actually curious to see how
they were going to do the actual
you know interaction between them
because i was like oh my i was bracing
myself i remember watching it i knew i
knew the story i knew she shot her and
she passed away and so i was like how
are they going to shoot this i don't
want to i kind of don't want to see
the actual tangible event i think the
way they shot it was with you know
moving like a blurry vision of something
running and like the ambulance and then
that ring with the egg that so iconic
that i don't know if it was scripted but
jennifer
like then she it sounded so just like
jennifer she's like it's an egg you know
it's like when she got
the ring and i was like oh all the
pieces and and how they brought it back
and she in the ring falls out of her
hand when she's in the ambulance and
then you know yeah that she has passed
away and i was like wow i was like
really well done that way yeah um that's
the crazy thing about this when this
movie came out every event of it was so
much in the in the public's
consciousness because
everybody knew the story she catapulted
she was already famous she was already
well known but she catapulted it's
literally worldwide renown because she
was right on the precipice of really
going to the next level and that sort of
tragedy really i think shakes people
mark what about you do you have a
favorite scene it's tough to top any of
those like real emotional gut punches
that you get towards the end and just
just playing a character like joan has
got to be so tough just given the
recency of the tragedy not happening
that long before
filming the movie and so
but the one that really struck me and
and it hit me again rewatching it was
when she went when selena is is just
sort of forced to to confront abraham
with the i love him scene like when she
says i love him and and and he kind of
steps in the way um of celine and
chris's relationship and it's just it's
this very sort of empowering moment but
it also you feel the strains of the of a
familial relationship that is is start
that has to grow and be nurtured or else
it's not going to work anymore so it was
just a really like heart-tugging
sequence for me to watch for whatever
reason i'm not sure what it was about
when she just has to announce that her
and chris and and john ceda is so great
in that role too it's it just really hit
me in a way that i wasn't expecting
because i knew it was coming this time
when i watched it again this week but
it's still it just it packs a wallop man
yeah um i don't know man i have so many
scenes that sort of stay in my heart but
uh como la flor when she calms the crowd
down after they're going like nuts for
her is one of my all-time favorites
first of all it's like one of my
favorite selena songs uh like that and
more prohibitor there's bigger hits i
think out there but those two are like
my favorites and um just the way that
she just slowed it down and then she
just smiles these this is literally they
show in the sequence at the end of the
movie that was selena's move she would
she would get the crowd right eating out
of the palm of her hand pause and smile
you know what i mean like and that was
like a signature of her performances and
i loved that scene it just um it showed
that she had such a power with her
audience that literally they're ready to
you know riot almost to try and get near
her and she could literally calm them
all down and give them literally like a
communal xanax with her voice so i i
love love that it's so cool that like
jennifer lopez career at that moment was
probably you know parallel to like the
idea of what she was portraying on
screen where it was like this is going
to be your life which is so weird i
think looking back at the footage of her
portraying selena
and jared lopez a newcomer into the
acting world not you know she's been a
fly girl like you said uh but like
really unknown at that point and then
almost to watch the movie and think wow
i wonder if she had any idea that she
was playing a superstar on stage and
singing and performing she had never no
cut an album before that and then
it just happened like it was almost like
a transition movie for her to to know
what it would feel like to go through
those emotions because she herself would
be feeling that for the rest of her life
yeah no i think like money train which
is what she did like a couple of years
before a year before selena and then
anaconda but the one that like sent her
over the edge was one she was doing this
with her music and then out of sight
when she did soderberg that's when she
like blew up and that was like a year
after selena so you're right it was just
like right she was right on the
precipice of making it um before we get
out of this though i'm sure there's
another scene uh harvey you have another
scene that you want to shout out from
the movie that you particularly love
yeah i mean i like the bus scene where
um she's just like it was nice to see
how playful jennifer was portraying
selena there was this one moment where
they're talking about like you know uh
what her dreams are and what her
ambitions are she was talking about
designing clothes and she's like
scribbling or something there's this
moment that the director caught where
jennifer just looks over and her hair
just falls on her face and it just
covers her face but not her eye and she
gives a smile and i was like those
little moments i was like they captured
really real moments not stage moments of
like and then you're gonna sit down and
then so for me it was those moments that
really breathed into like uh humanity
where i was like that's such a cool
moment and the camera just happened to
be on and they just caught it you know
and you still feel like you're you're
watching selena even all these years
later when we know who jennifer lopez
became you still feel like you're
watching selena it like i i it very
rarely was i taken out of the movie and
and thought oh jlo was giving a great
performance here because she just
becomes that character and all those
concert scenes like i love a good
concert sequence that feels realistic in
a movie because so few of them are able
to pull it off that well they literally
when they were making the movie they
they had 30 40 000 people show up
just to watch these scenes be filmed and
they ended up making it look like it was
a real concert and just to pull that off
to have the loyal fan base even after
celina's passing to show up and honor
her in that way and for that for those
crowds to give jlo the the freedom to
become selena i just thought it it's
remarkable to see how well it still
holds up i will have quibbles as a as a
person that lived in south texas for a
long time with jennifer lopez's texas
accent there is a different form of
texas accent
in south texas than straight texas i
want like south of san antonio that is a
different accent like you get down
brownsville but i will forgive her of
that that'd be like a new yorker like
being like oh yeah that's a queen's
accent versus a manhattan accent so like
nobody else is gonna call those balls
and strikes except for me but they're
there i was gonna say one of the things
that i remember that became such an
iconic line was uh you know when you see
those guys the low riders are like hey
anything for salinas you know just like
the infliction of that i was like okay
it's a literal well you know a little
much but okay i'll forgive because it
was like hey that's you know just like
over-the-top accent there are people who
talk about obviously but i was like okay
we don't need to like we don't need to
go this far
[Applause]
[Music]
she looks just like salinas
rewind come on
[Applause]
i can pull anything out of anywhere also
like again
again it's like
that guy would not be there the writers
is like a different part of texas like
these are like where's this low rider
guy i was like maybe in east los like if
you're in east los and maybe like you
know san antonio houston you can do that
a bit but in corpus where they were that
is just not the t sorry like i'm
literally like like
and they're in the middle of the desert
and i was like
i wouldn't know that backstory i was
like what are those guys in the
convertible doing in the middle of the
desert
like you would way more find a like kind
of like
you know s kicker as we like to say
kicker i'm going to just say it a
hispanic dude with like a jacked up
truck in that part of texas than you
would be to find a low rider i'm just
giving y'all facts you can fight me
later i'm not saying they aren't there
i'm living my truth i lived it but i had
a really nice like sprinkle of like
because it's an iconic scene and
everyone does that now so anything for
salinas you know yes you know you're
saying her name right it's not salinas
but that's the but that's again it
became awkward to iconic and that is
the testament of a movie that is so
beloved i will have to mention this
scene just because it is actually one
that i see like come out a lot because
it is like the greatest i made it moment
and it is the moment with selena in the
mall at the grammys
when you know the woman she comes up and
i guess um um
she's trying to address one of her one
of her friends and she's just like okay
we got to get you a dress really quickly
um let's go to the mall obviously this
was the last minute thing and the
woman's like she's like i need to see
this dress she's like oh you don't want
to see that one it's 800 which by the
way sure as heck would have happened in
these malls at this time and it's like
the pretty woman moment yeah it's the
pretty woman moment and
then like everybody swamps it because
that was actually true selena was so
famous that like anywhere she went where
people knew an inch of who she was they
just wanted to get near her and like and
and come say hi and i think she was very
open about the fact that she was always
out there you know she was at her shop
she was in corpus she was going to
whataburger like there'd be all these
stories like oh i was you know behind
the line with uh selena whataburger that
people would talk about stuff like that
or whatever so she was very um close to
her fan base and so i think that scene
was great and then jennifer lopez played
it perfectly when she looked back we
don't need the dress i was like yes
so what's going on in here
who's selena she's here for the grammys
the grammys
stuff
what do you think
me either
excuse me miss excuse me
we don't need the dress
and fun story the actress who played her
best friend in that scene yeah ended up
playing her mother in the series oh my
gosh i did not know that yeah we haven't
talked about the series but we
absolutely should because they're they
just finished part two for the series
and that has some really incredible
moments too that were both in this and
seen through like a different lens
because like again it's sort of like
doing marilyn rowe there's iconic
outfits that you think of and so like
the big purple outfit is one of them we
kind of talked to her a little bit
already about the music um as a fan of
her music what was your favorite sort of
performance harvey um from the film i
mean i really like
i love all the songs but like for me the
performance was the iconic at the
astrodome
just like
the finale um which technically wasn't
her last concert i did some research her
last concert was not there but it was
the biggest uh concert she had uh before
her passing and so for me it was so
ironic to see that again the purple
outfit bringing back the 70s with the
bell-bottom jumpsuit uh and and the
moves just because it was the the disco
medley
and then she was like working in the
dance and i was like oh my gosh this is
so great and and knowing that it was
coming to an end like the climax was
that like he knew that it was like this
is it like you knew because you knew the
backstory so even if you know you're
just watching in the back of your hair
like it's coming it's coming soon you
know it's like this almost like
this climax to this like roller coaster
that you're like i don't even want to
get there and i'm about to just and then
it happens so for me that was such a
moment because it wasn't that long ago
that we saw that performance you know uh
being played on tv over and over for her
anniversary and so uh yeah so that's for
me was an iconic moment yeah i will add
to that one too what i thought was great
about that is that disco medley that she
did which was a huge um on the air hit
um in south texas where i was from i
don't know where it played everywhere
else but it was a big deal where i was
from um and
that i think showed where she was going
to go with her english language because
one of her biggest influences i honestly
think is donna summer you can't listen
to her slow songs and not kind of think
of macarthur park and listen to her
upbeat songs and not think of the more
disco-infused stuff that donna summer
did i always felt that she was
so influenced by that yes pop stars and
all of that other one but when you
really looked at who she was as an
artist like she definitely talked so
much more about emotional stuff that
also could have an incredible beat to it
so i loved it that that was where she
was with uh her musical performance on
that one i think you're right yeah that
would have been a timeline when she was
little in the 70s scene at her dad's
restaurant that would have been around
the time that all these hits would have
been coming out with you know john
summer like so that sounds perfectly
accurate
yeah like again i don't know this for
sure but whenever i used to hear her
that was the first thing i would think
and so when she made that disco medley i
was like i got it like i feel like it's
like like leonardo dicaprio once upon a
time hollywood that's it
uh mark what about you uh favorite
musical moment
um my favorite salinas song is is
probably dreaming of you but i also like
the uh
the cheek uh you have to forget my awful
accent uh what she could do
a pardon
yes it's 512 yes yes and um and so
i have trouble remembering all the songs
that actually get performed within the
context of the film but the the concert
sequences themself not just the way they
were shot but the way that the actual
family responded to them because their
apparent the story goes there was one
concert sequence that they filmed in
front of like
tens of thousands of people and
afterwards selena's mom came up and
hugged j-lo because she like she was
watching her daughter again and that's
again because you're talking about
someone who
who
they didn't want cast as they wanted to
cast like a non
latinx person to play selena and so the
director had to fight for jennifer lopez
just to get a shot to play selena in the
movie and then the commitment that she
showed once she got it where she moved
in with her sister and she she did more
than just like mimic the moves on stage
like she really did everything she could
to
to embody and honor the role that she
was playing absolutely and that's why it
is like an uncanny valley where it's
eerie she really does disappear and this
is jennifer lopez like i'm literally
watching her you know making out on a
tarmac with ben affleck two days ago but
that to me is in no way similar to the
woman that you see in this movie even
though i know in my heart it is but like
i can't see her in this i just see
uh what she's trying to get across from
us and so yeah it's a really really
incredible performance you already
talked about harvey about the quotes
from the movie with salinas
sorry
i i literally i'm like this just feels
wrong
to say it but that's what it did that's
what it is i'm just trying to be
accurate to quote um another quote for
you i already said mine you can keep the
dress uh we don't need the dress sorry i
think that uh the quote is where she's
doing the press conference in mexico
city the fa and us and they're asking
the questions like i thought she spoke
spanish yeah i thought she was like she
was like i'll be fine and she'll like
and she's like chopped up spanish she's
like uh so is that felicia you know
they're asking us in spanish are you
excited to be in mexico city
yeah i saw muy um
excited you know
like and she still won them over because
she wasn't trying to put on air she was
like look yes i speak a little bit of
spanish i'm not like completely you know
but she was just like so for me it kind
of was really nice because uh you know
being first generation american and
learning a different language in the
household and then going to school and
it's completely different like two
worlds when you walk through the
threshold sometimes you feel like you
have to prove yourself to one or the
other you're rather not mexican enough
you know to to be part of the community
or you're not wide enough to be part of
the america you know so it was kind of
like watching that i was like oh i was
like you know what she doesn't like
she's not apologetic she's just like
yeah i'm i'm trying here you know i mean
i'm just doing it that's who i am i'm
just and like i speak both not great but
i can speak but so it was really nice to
see that and it was like a genuine
moment that was a real moment for selena
she wasn't you know she tried her best
uh didn't speak it completely perfect
but she didn't stop trying so
much
[Laughter]
and i mean it was abe's sort of like
guidance that told her like if you sing
in spanish you can make an impression
you could be a trailblazer
i already did it the other way
do it this way that's why that opening
scene is so interesting mark any any
favorite pull quotes from you on this
one well the one that reminded it
reminded me of you you may not be a huge
fan of the particular quote but it's
when her and chris were talking about
and and she's like don't go to corpus is
it's like at the anywhere but corpus
christi moment when they're like alaska
is better than corpus christi at this
particular point in their lives so i
didn't want to bring it up jacqueline
but if you put me on the spot i mean
look i enjoy whataburger for what it is
so
you know i would have no problem hanging
out with you in your hometown
look this is the one thing i will say no
matter what like affinity i have for
like corpus in my upbringing this is
also like there's just not a lot of
teenagers we want to escape i wanted to
go
with all of the hippy dippy people in
austin i needed to find my tribe and so
i was trying to get there as quickly as
possible i'm way more similar to um
elliot page sorry their name elliot page
and whip it
where she's just like i have to get out
of bodine that was me and corpus like i
have to get out of corpus like i i
cannot stay here so but i still have
love for it um we've kind of touched on
it a little bit but let's talk a bit
about the you know we talked about them
individually but let's kind of do the
greatest hits with the cast because this
was cast in incredibly well with
really talented really um authentic
um hispanic actors from the ones that
had done you know oscar nominated work
to to newer faces that would become sort
of like household names so
yeah harvey go ahead and break down your
faves and if you want to jayla we've
already we've already given her her
flowers but anybody in the supporting
cast well i mean i i think i'll go back
to lu pontiveros you know just plain
yolanda
where we know who this person was she's
a villain from the get-go so you already
know this but this i mean the way they
dressed her in the similarities were so
uh uncannick i was like wow this looks
like
really perfect casting and edward james
almost of course and i just recently got
to um
talk to him and i just didn't want to
like fanboy out with him
and i was like oh he's on our
network for a sister show and it was
just like we're doing something with
like uh pr and stuff and i was like oh
my goodness
like it was like it's it's the singer
so it's kind of like for me it's those
two that really kind of make the
ensemble uh complete like everyone was
perfectly cast so starting with jennifer
and then with lupe and um and edward so
it was perfect mark what about you real
quick before we uh get to getting harvey
talking about what we do in the shadows
and some other stuff before we get out
of this section who was your favorite in
the sporting cast i thought jackie
guerra was great
um as as suzette but then like you i i
can't escape edward james almost and i
just i sort of feel for the guy in real
life because whenever he walks down the
street at any one point he's gonna have
hordes of different types of people that
all love him for roles that he played
because you're going to have the
battlestar galactica fans that just want
to get selfies you have all the selena
fans and then you have me over here just
waving like i like the baseball movie
for the love of the game you know
he's great in everything but but the
suzette character i also thought was
brought a lot to the movie yeah i know
suzette i i'm gonna give it up for uh
constance marie who i just love her in
anything i just feel like her face is
one that i want to follow um around and
other stuff she was also in the george
lopez show which i also like watched uh
extensively when that show was on here
so no she's great um
speaking of you know
before we leave like selena the movie
they did do the netflix show it's
interesting because i have people who
are like split on it there's people that
favorite harvey what did you feel on the
netflix show did you watch it
i did watch it uh i just like the fun
facts about you know uh the actress who
ended up playing the mom in the series
played selena's best friend uh who goes
with her to beverly hills shopping for
the dress and whatnot so that was really
cool to know that little fun fact but i
did feel like the series focused more on
the family story so you focus on the
brother uh a b and the dad and so it was
nice to to see that story line fleshed
out more that was like oh i didn't know
that was happening at the same time this
was happening because we're focusing on
one person's lives in the movie
obviously uh you know selena and then in
the series like oh was that oh i didn't
know that was happening i didn't know
that their marriage was having a little
bit of a rocky moment i didn't know that
this was happening in the background
there was more members in the band that
we didn't see in the movie that they
have back stories as well so it was nice
to see those backstories where
they omitted some of the
band members in the movie and then the
series i was like oh that's right
because i always wondered that guy with
the long hair
i was like who's he and now we know a
little backstory and they give him a
story i was like oh and then he ends up
having to leave and like all this stuff
you know spoiler if you haven't seen but
like you know it was nice to see that
backstory for the people around this
character that we've uh all grown to
love and knew about nice to know those
other humans also have stories you know
and they're beautiful so that was nice
yeah i know i think my favorite and i'm
again not trying to be whatever but you
know
[Music]
but i didn't care i knew about the
selena beyonce moment like i absolutely
knew about that moment before the series
and i got actually mad at twitter
because people are like they're just oh
they don't know because they're both
from texas i'm like no no back when she
was barely out of girl time and it was
like first album of destiny's child and
i'm talking like latavia destiny's child
she told that story about meeting selena
and i knew that interview i had watched
that interview and so i knew that that
was real and so i actually appreciated
seeing that in the series and it sort of
showed which was true which is that no
i'm not just part of the hispanic
culture but if you were there at that
time
that was yours too like this was what
people from that area were talking about
and you could feel it especially when
she passed because i mean people were
inconsolable people didn't know how to
you know go to school the next day i
remember like several people like called
out because they just didn't know what
to do and it wasn't just because she was
a girl that made hits it was again
because she was so accessible to their
fans and she was considered to be such a
hometown hero so it uh it definitely
shows the power of community and music
and i think that's why again definitely
deserves to be above 67 percent
well said yeah she was a bridge you know
she united a lot of different types of
people if you see footage of all the
memorials that they had around that time
it's all different demographics that are
all coming together just to mourn and
and you're right i mean it's it's even
it goes even a step further than a lot
of other times when you see musicians
pass away unexpectedly tragically and
they they have all these great
observances for them but that one it
just hits different we are not going to
get out of here without talking about
what we do in the shadows first of all
congratulations on last season actually
i think i talked to you
at the beginning or maybe the end of
last season and like we were just
starting to figure out where your
character was going with all of his
newfound power and then the emmys came
out and y'all got nominated so just to
sort of like recap from previous how was
that what was that moment for you
because i know you guys campaigned
so so hard to give that show in front of
emmy voters and to hopefully get it
nominated i mean that it was it's so
weird because you know we're now filming
we're halfway through season four but
two of our seasons have been under a
pandemic so we've actually aired season
two and it was right at the beginning of
it so i remember the first uh the week
that we're getting excited it's our
second season um and we're really pumped
about it and the emmys were coming up
and we wanted to you know people to
watch the show and then pandemic
happened we didn't have a premiere party
and um but because of that i think in a
weird way more people were at home and
and had the time to be like oh you know
i'm gonna check this out so that year we
got eight emmy nominations just because
it was like whoa what is the show and
people couldn't consume it fast enough
now the bad part was that because of the
panama we're still figuring out how to
get back to work safely
so it delayed everything a little bit so
because of that we had to postpone uh
the premiere for season three uh into
the following uh year which is this year
so in this year we've actually shot in
the last 10 months we shot a whole
season which is season three and we're
halfway done season four
wow
so we're pumping it out for you guys as
fast as we can um and then this will be
airing uh next year so it's like we're
trying to play catch up because the
pandemic actually you know took two
years of our life um and everything you
know was out of uh out of order so we're
just now like come on let's go let's go
and so we're pumping it out which is
nice because you just finished season
three and everyone's like on pins and
needles you won't have to wait a whole
year
to see it again it'll be faster than
it's it's ever been in the past uh
because we were able to do it in one
year oh that is music to my ears i am so
excited i i love the show and and one of
the things i really get to kick out of
watching it is just as i'm sure
everybody does when they check it out
what is the the sort of freedom that you
all have with the dialogue to sort of
play around and and improv is it is it
all on the page what we see on when
we're watching it on tv or is is there a
little bit of your own stuff that you're
bringing into each scene that you have
sort of that leeway to to change words
or maybe just go off on tangents yeah
absolutely we followed the formula that
taikan germain uh did for the movie
which was they well they did it
differently they had a script that they
knew they wanted and they never gave
that script to the actors they kept it
to themselves and they when they
actually showed up to work they would
just tell them exactly what was
happening like you have to open that
door uh talk about getting groceries and
then exit out the door and that's it go
and so you go along with that but with
our show we have a team of amazing
writers who
and we did the scripted version we'd be
fine and fantastic but we do get the
freedom to do what we call funsies it's
becoming the ongoing joke so we do a
scripted version and then we do a
funsies where it's like you know what
we're doing you know what the story is
you know you have to get a word for word
but make it your your own as your
character and i would say that 50 of
what you see on on screen final cut is
is scripted 50 and 50 is improvised
i like that i mean i think it's a
pressure cooker but based on the fact
that the show has only gotten better
like this last season is the highest
rated that you guys had and people were
talking again and just how incredible it
was it's 100 like you guys started
pretty good at like 94 then 98 but then
now in the third season where other
shows go down you guys are like taking
it up a notch and
not to like put too many spoilers out
there folks should have seen it by now
it's been over a year but
the the way we sort of like leave your
character in the end of season three i
think i don't know like can you at least
you know kind of tell us what you think
is gonna happen next or or you know what
i mean
yeah it's we see that we think we
finally
see guillermo getting what he wants and
potentially taking the step in the right
direction and unfortunately
he is uh put in a trunk and sealed and
sent across the atlantic ocean to
england to protect nausea so everyone's
doing something out of love so
laszlo's reaction to protecting his lady
love is sending me with her to protect
her as a bodyguard because i'm a good
bodyguard but unfortunately he doesn't
care about what my desires are because i
have plans to meet someone at the train
station and then that person thinks i
stood them up and now they leave without
me and now i'm in a trunk with orioles
and pedialyte
to hold me across my transatlantic
so
oreo's impedia light like the minute i
saw that i was like vampires really have
no idea what it takes no idea humans
yeah
i can appreciate what laszlo did for his
love but it also has a ripple effect you
know everyone's actually has a reaction
and so uh it sets us up for where do we
go like we are separated also we colin
robinson passed away uh because they
only lived to be a hundred years old and
spoiler he hadn't seen it but there's
also rebirth so with every you know
death there's a rebirth and so we're
bringing that up and so where does this
leave us i mean season four picks up
where you know uh time has gone by and
we'll see uh where everyone's at at
their uh previous or current stages in
life
i love it oh this is so exciting and i i
don't i now i just love thinking about
what we do in shadows in the context of
it's like a it's like a cereal box and
it just says now with 50 more funsies
if we extrapolate that further is there
is there one particular scene you can
remember of any of the seasons you've
done or one of the episodes a scene
where
everybody broke and you just could not
stop laughing you just couldn't get it
back together because it was just such a
funny moment it's i mean there's a scene
we're doing around the table i think it
was season two um where were the ghosts
episode yeah i think this is the
beginning of season two um the ghost
episode where we're all around the
sean's table and nadja is like
she's singing and it was just like the
ridiculous like singing that she was
doing and then i think at one point
laszlo we hear a noise and it's colin
robinson's knee that hit the table and
then we're like you hear that's a ghost
and then i think matt says something
like i think it's one of tommy squeakers
sounds over there like
he was like saying like that guillermo
was you know uh passing gas at the table
and i was like he just improvised that
and i just couldn't stop laughing like
uncontrollably and they actually use a
really quick clip in the scene where i
didn't think they would but i look over
at uh at nandor and he's laughing but
we're not even laughing in character
we're laughing ourselves and like they
used that clip in the show so when i
watched the episode i was like oh my god
they kept it i was like we broke but
they kept it as and it still goes smooth
with the idea of us hanging out around
table because it was organic it felt
real and it was you caught real laughter
on the screen oh that's great that's
awesome
well listen i literally could talk about
this show forever but you're a busy man
with more folks to talk to about uh
season three and and what else is coming
up for what we do in the shadows but
before we let you get out of here as you
are a man in the know who likes to watch
things do you have a recommendation for
our listeners to check out um as a movie
or feature or anything in particular
whatever you want you can give up you
know anything
um i would say
um i try to balance things out so since
i do comedy i go home and the way that i
decompress is watching
bad reality tv
and when i say bad i mean it's good yeah
it's really good um so i'm obsessed with
the housewives right now like the real
housewives of beverly hills in that
drama like this is like not even
scripted this is like real life there's
a lot of drama going on there's a lot of
drama going on and so i like to like uh
go away from what i do for a living and
then watch other people watch what they
do for a living
or what they shouldn't be doing for a
living and sure that's not i'm just a
big fan of it so if you want to you know
switch away from watching scripted uh tv
and scripted comedy or dramas try a
reality show you won't be disappointed
it just puts a pep in your step when
when you watch the housewives because i
i leave every episode like thank god i'm
not dealing with that thank god
i feel good i'm like that's that's
dramatic and i want nothing to do with
that
i love it well thank you so much harvey
this has been a treat yet again please
come back with ever whatever you're
you're you're promoting we would love to
chat with you and folks if you have not
with shame on you caught up on what we
do in the shadows all three seasons are
streaming now on hulu and you can catch
up now just in time for the very
apparently quickly coming season 4.
thanks guy
[Music]
i love chatting with him he is such a
warm ray of sunshine and if again if you
guys have not seen what we do in the
shadows you are missing out has some of
the best comedy and some of the best
guest stars on television because many
of them like us love the show some of
the best guffaws and i'm not just saying
and highlighting the episode that has my
guy mark hamill in it but the just the
name even if you haven't seen the show
you probably have heard somebody say the
name jackie daytona and i
i implore you to go check out not just
that season of it start with season one
and work your way because it's just it's
a riot it's a it's such a great concept
it's one of those things that i saw when
i first saw the movie that taika did and
i said i wish i thought of that concept
it's that smart
yeah and honestly rush through that and
honestly it's
anything taika what td or jermaine
clement does is hilarious go find flight
of concords go watch their new show
reservoir dogs i mean these guys were
meant to tell fun and interesting
stories and that's kind of what they've
been doing uh since they came onto the
scene so i'm so excited for that
no mail bag today please guys don't get
mad at us we've just had some really
incredible guests and we wanted to give
you as much time with them as possible
but we will rip open the mail bag soon
in the meantime keep emailing us
subscribe rate review tell your friends
the podcast has been growing so much and
we appreciate it we know it is from you
the ketchup crew that we were able to do
this and we do it for you you think we
could just do a mailbag we're just we
talk about a bunch of different movies
that's not going to be next week next
week it's another very special episode
with a very special guest so stay tuned
for that and in the meantime rate review
whatever
however you're listening to us do
whatever that platform asks you to do to
uh support our podcast we could not be
doing this without y'all and be running
as long as we have so thanks to our
fresh ketchup crew yes and we will see
y'all next week bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you